[Música]
porque con nuestra primera invitada del
día vamos a hablar del bacha bazi una
práctica cada vez más común en
afganistán tras el regreso de los
talibanes al poder en la que los niños y
adolescentes son víctimas de abuso y
esclavitud sexual nos acompaña entonces
maría paula martínez ella es directora
de save the children en colombia maría
paula gracias por estar con nosotros
esta mañana en directo américa de france
24 un placer estar acá maría paula pues
hablemos digamos de esta práctica
lamentable que se utiliza en afganistán
y sabe del todo digamos o más popular
atrás el regreso nuevamente los
talibanes al poder pero para
contextualizar a nuestra audiencia
hablemos primero de qué significa el
bacha bazi pues básicamente es tomar a
los niños maquillar los o vestir les
como mujer exhibir los y muchas veces
estas prácticas llegan hasta el abuso y
pueden terminar en una explotación
sexual comercial porque digamos que esta
práctica ellos la justifican diciendo
que es algo cultural que es algo digamos
normalizado en la sociedad de afganistán
en muchos países y muchos contextos hay
muchas prácticas que se normalizan sin
embargo afganistán tiene una ley que
salió en el 2017 que prohíbe esta
práctica es decir que el compromiso para
el gobierno actual y para todos los que
ayudamos a los gobiernos alrededor del
mundo a implementar las leyes que
protegen a los niños es hacer que esa
ley sea conocida y que la violencia
contra los niños sea eliminada pero
digamos que porque en este caso de
afganistán no se respete no se cumple
sería cabalidad si tiene que ver
evidentemente con el regreso de los
talibanes al poder para podemos no sea
también hacer una comparación de cuando
estaban las tropas estadounidenses y
cuando estaba después del gobierno
anterior y cuando estaban los talibanes
realmente si se respetaba un poco más
los derechos de los niños pues yo diría
que en países que viven distintas crisis
y naciones unidas así lo establecido
afganistán sigue viviendo la crisis del
hambre la crisis y los efectos del
cobach 19 y los del cambio climático
viene de varios años de pandemia y de
conflicto armado y eso exacerba
inevitablemente los riesgos que sufren
los niños
niñas en este tipo de contextos entonces
efectivamente si tenemos prácticas que
son condenadas es decir que invitan a
más violencia contra los niños ya que
los adultos no seamos garantes de sus
derechos pues es ahí donde todos seamos
reaccionar y actuar la comunidad
internacional digamos y países vecinos
no podrían estar ayudando también a que
los derechos de los niños y sean
respetados que no sean vulnerados que no
sean explotados sexualmente
efectivamente en muchas ongs que están
presentes en kabul sobre todo y en
varias partes de afganistán en varias de
sus regiones contribuyan en este momento
asistimos en el para el 2022 a 43
millones de personas en necesidad en
afganistán donde 13 millones son niños y
niñas 8 millones de niños no han
regresado al colegio entonces todas las
actividades que hacemos muchos de
nosotros para hacer que la educación
comunitaria se siga dando para
fortalecer los sistemas de protección en
varias de los estados y regiones de
afganistán y en que la sociedad en
general tanto de los países vecinos como
interna dentro de afganistán entienda
que la oportunidad de invertir en los
niños es ahora y para siempre pues es el
gran legado que vamos a dejar como
comunidad internacional en este tipo de
contextos maría paula le pregunto qué
tan difícil es trabajar en países como
afganistán en pro del bienestar de los
niños o sea no sé si alguno de ustedes
como como la organización save the
children han tenido algún tipo de
acercamiento con los talibanes ahora en
el poder para poder trabajar para poder
ayudarlos más allá de lo que ocurre en
la sociedad como lo tocamos en el
término de los guayabas y pues
necesariamente tenemos que estar
acreditados tanto las agencias del
sistema de naciones unidas como las ongs
para seguir ayudando a quien más nos
necesita y quien más lo necesita son 9.2
millones de personas que se han
desplazado en los últimos años y que
siguen retornando en condiciones de
máxima pobreza son esos 8 millones de
niños que todavía muchos de ellos no
tienen una educación formal y estable
son las niñas que durante la pandemia
tanto en afganistán como en colombia
como en otros contextos donde se
presentan grandes crisis sufren todo
tipo de violencia en ese sentido si
podemos trabajar la cooperación
internacional ha hecho unos llamamientos
enormes de financiamiento para seguir
con las actividades y ahora empezamos a
prepararnos todos para el invierno que
es cuando más sufren los niños y las
niñas y sus familias digamos cuando los
derechos de los niños se ven vulnerados
sobre todo en la parte de una
explotación sexual cómo trabajar a esos
niños para que realmente tengan una vida
dentro de lo que cabe pues se plena y
poder superar estos abusos y esta
vulneración de sus derechos como trabaja
para organización en este caso save the
children para poder salvarlos
rescatarlos de estas prácticas abusivas
pues lo primero y alrededor del mundo es
la conciencia que todos los niños tienen
de sus derechos todos los niños se
merecen ser felices y ser educados tener
acceso a la salud al agua potable a
comer varias veces al día a que su
familia los cuida que los adultos que
estamos a su alrededor les garantizamos
la protección en esa medida en nuestros
espacios amigables en nuestros espacios
en todas nuestras actividades que
hacemos de educación comunitaria le
damos el espacio a los niños para que
ellos entiendan cuáles son sus derechos
y si están en capacidad de reclamar los
lo haga efectivamente esto no va en
contra de la cultura de los países pero
por el contrario apoyan muchos de los
mensajes que desde la misma base
comunitaria y con personal y staff
afgano tanto mujeres como hombres
nosotros podemos pasar ciertos mensajes
por otra parte trabajamos con los
adultos fortaleciendo sus sistemas de
protección y tratando de que todos los
adultos entiendan que somos garantes de
los derechos y que no hay excusa para no
proteger a los niños y evitarles
cualquier tipo de violencia claro pero
también digamos que es complicado yo
aquí pensando en esta conversación un
niño que culturalmente crece pues como
estos niños bailarines en afganistán por
poner este ejemplo
y lo ve digamos normalizado como
entender que esta práctica realmente no
está bien que realmente esta práctica
vulnera sus derechos que luego van a
estar explotados sexualmente como un
niño se da cuenta y es realmente
consciente que está siendo explotado que
está haciendo
como no debería ser los niños lo saben
los niños son muy inteligentes sin
embargo no tienen opciones aparte de eso
muchas veces para sobrevivir cuando
muchos niños son metidos en dinámicas de
trata de personas de explotación sexual
comercial es porque el abuso de sus
familias la falta de amor la falta de
cuidado o la necesidad de llevar comida
a su casa los han llevado a este tipo de
prácticas en esa medida la desigualdad
la inequidad la lucha contra la pobreza
sigue siendo en este momento de vital
importancia y como hablábamos a
organizarme es uno de los países que se
encuentran como en el 'top ten' de los
países que sufren hambre son muchas
poblaciones las que no están comiendo
muchos niños en desnutrición 3.9
millones de niños que tienen estado
desnutrición es cuando tú tienes la
mezcla entre gente que no tiene
oportunidades de vida que todavía sigue
desafiando una reconstrucción de un país
muy lentamente
bueno hace que pues la conciencia sobre
la protección de los niños en ese tipo
de contextos en ese tipo de crisis y con
aliados que están dispuestos a apoyar
pues sea la solución para seguir
intentando hacer lo posible para
proteger a nuestros niños alrededor del
mundo